une grande première dans les yvelines un
parc aquatique gonflable est installé
depuis le 1er juillet sur l'île de
loisirs des boucles de seine à moisson
d'une capacité maximale de 70 personnes
la structure peut accueillir des enfants
à partir de 6 ans et il n'y a pas de
limite d'âge pour gravir les obstacles
on peut faire des sauts on voit qu'à une
tour à trois mètres de haut et non car à
gravir il peut faire des mondes et des
sauts périlleux et toboggan donc après
celle équilibre c'est la glisse pas nos
enfants d'appréhender aussi leur leurs
peurs sur les plus petits et bas de
faire des défis personnels aussi
et se dire au début je pas y arriver et
continuer de me voir ils ont tous réussi
sont contents d'avoir fait activités en
fait après un peu plus d'une heure sur
l'eau a grimpé à se défouler première
réaction c'est bien c'est sa fatigue un
peu mais
j'aime bien c'est recommandé moi j'ai
bien aimé parce qu'il y avait c'était
grand et tout genre y avait les parcours
et moi je trouve ça cool on s'est
beaucoup amusé et ben on a fait la santé
on a
on a fait des parcours surtout on a fait
du toboggan et tout ça
oui j'ai vraiment adoré c'était trop
bien le tarif est de 7 euros pour 30
minutes et 10 euros pour une heure si
vous voulez tester le parc aquatique
gonflable est ouvert sept jours sur sept
jusqu'au 31 août